turn it up a media conference lucemon
exactly but lately Western belt or we
have had the occasion this afternoon to
have the videoconference with the
Western Balkans partners as you probably
know we intended to have this summit in
Zagreb and the crashing presidency but
because of the covet 19 it was not
possible it was very important 20 years
after the first that Rep summit to have
this video conference to have this
occasion in order to tackle very
important challenges that we need to
face together and of course the first
important topic is the cravat 19 because
it's important for the European member
states but also in partnership with the
partners in the Western Balkan region to
overcome this very difficult challenge
and that's why we have taken as European
Union some very important decisions
which shows our solidarity with this
region we provide 3.3 billion euros in
assistance in the short term in the mid
term for this region in order to support
the width of each strategy in this
region it's also very important to
repeat Seop on Union that it's essential
for us to work in the framework of the
g7 either g20 I mean at the global level
because this crisis is global and it
requires a global solution that's why we
consider that this international
cooperation is so important the certain
important topic that we have discussed
during this summit this afternoon is the
European perspective of the Western
Balkans partners is a very important
signal it's a very important message
that we have we affirmed that we have
weakened found and it was essential to
if this strong position to express
distant position it means that it's
important to continue the which forms to
implement the which forms the rule of
law the democratic values the fight
against corruption those topics are
essential for the benefit of the
citizens or the benefit of the people
but also in order to strengthen the
partnerships between this region and the
European Union I would like also to use
this occasion to welcome the decision
that we have taken regarding the opening
of the negotiation store with North
Macedonia and with Albania
Oct 6 2014 11 2002 the classroom the
real female pre-owned vote each lap SBT
European posted resume we said since she
teleported the reform Tommo all of it
little dude what
oh yeah a vector Laval a democratic
election which control team organized II
do have arrested the Proheat it would
have its own steps of relocation develop
literacy cell we deserve on signal to
the fate of the retrieve the Thomson
dollar regime not mo non-catholic
respond Alamos Trentino
in a dress we don't care the electrode
Amity in from salvation you know L bill
lamp limitations echo a 2 cm for
important for continued II met home
place in the mid positive what the
result at Walla they tell to the limited
reporters Avenue when the data resume IT
valid it spring set on vision with the
traditional plant a national a special
mobile sequence analyzer which said
resume from a perspective on a fermion
process hua 18 beds BtoB don't you can
save up a I now give the floor to the
President of the European Commission
yes thank you very much thank you
challenge and Thank You Andrey indeed
we've had very good discussions between
the European Union and our Western
Balkan
discussions on our common challenges and
how to take forward our cooperation this
summit even if it's virtual it's a
testimony of the importance the European
Union gives to the region testimony that
the Western Balkans are an absolute
priority for the European Union and for
my Commission the Western Balkans belong
in the EU and there is no question for
us about it and this is why I firmly
believe that the European Union has a
special responsibility in assisting its
partners in the region this is
particularly true regarding the impact
of the coronavirus
there were many strong signs of
solidarity in difficult time going back
and forth I want to thank very much the
countries in the region for their
solidarity with the European Union I
recall that Albanian doctors went to
help Italy and Serbia and Montenegro
helped enormously to fly back home
EU citizens that were stranded the
donation of protective equipment for
example made to Italy on Monday this is
another sign we had a global pledging
conference we collected globally 8
billion dollars and more than four
billion dollars came from the so called
team Europe and Serbia was part of that
team by pledging to I think that is a
strong and very clear message likewise
the European Union has mobilized an
unparalleled financial package indeed of
the 3.3 billion euros 750 million euros
have been a macro economic financial
assistance so it has been designed to
help the Western Balkans to address the
immediate needs in the health sector but
also of course to take the first
measures to mitigate the social economic
impact and to inject liquidity to small
and medium sized companies in the
western region this has been done
together with the European investment
we have also associated our Western
Balkan partners in the European Union
initiatives that are normally only
reserved for member states for example
with the joint procurement initiative to
buy medical supplies like masks and
ventilators but also in the concept of
the so-called Green Lanes crossing the
borders that helped enormously to have
the flow of goods going oh this is a
demonstration that the Western Balkans
are privileged partners giving given our
unequivocal commitment to the European
perspective once we put behind us this
immediate phase of the coronavirus
crisis the European Union will accompany
the longer term recovery with an
economic and investment plan I expect
the plan to be presented later in the
year because of course it's linked to
our European budget I can already tell
you that the investment plan itself will
focus on the necessary transport and
energy infrastructure infrastructure to
interconnect our regions but also in our
main policies that are the European
Green Deal or the digital transition
which we also which will also be at the
heart of the European Union's recovery
the regional cooperation and good
neighborhood relations are key for the
economic recovery in the region we know
this too well in Europe where our single
market is our strength and we want the
Western Balkans also to get closer to
the single market and benefit from it
for this governments in the region will
need to continue to deliver on reforms
particularly in the area of the rule of
law and the fight against corruption and
the functioning of the democratic
institutions and public administration
this means tackling corruption and
organized crimes where we want to see a
clear track record established
let me stress in particular that a free
press it's also a poner stone of
democracy and in the Europeans DNA we
know if we want to fight this
information we need a strong and a free
press this is the best mean against this
information but it will also give the
possibility to those countries that show
faster tangible results in reforms to
move faster in the accession
negotiations opening more chapters in
one go this is the new methodology which
we adopted earlier this year I'm
particularly happy that the summit takes
place and Croatia council presidency our
newest member in the European Union it
is in this creation presidency that the
European Council decided to give the
green light to open accession talks with
North Macedonia and Albania a strong
sign we have just celebrated a few days
ago the biggest enlargement to the
European Union 16 years ago the
enlargement policy this is something
where I'm deeply convinced is one of the
most successful EU policies is it has
spread peace security and prosperity
across the continent and I'm sure it
will continue to be the benefit of the
Western Balkans and the European Union
thank you thank you madam president
passing the floor now to Zagreb to prime
minister plan coverage thank you very
much thank you
Cheryl Thank You Ursula it was really a
privilege for Croatia to be a virtual
host of the Zagreb summit which was
planned for many years it was the far
project and the centerpiece of our
presidency of the council I was
personally present back in Zagreb 2000
when the first type of this summit was
held under the French presidency at the
time since then Croatia has passed
really a long demanding way towards the
European Union and we have used the
enlargement process
and the accession process as a true
transformative exercise for our
political legal and economic system we
have been in the Union for seven years
we are the youngest and the latest
member of the Union and therefore being
a country that understands very much
what our first neighbors countries of
Western Balkans countries of Southeast
Europe are seeking for we wanted to
organize this summit in order to send
them a strong signal that the European
Union is here standing by them and is
willing to help them on their way to the
European Union as also like I said the
enlargement policy was one of the most
successful policies throughout Europe 70
years history and our ambition was
during the Croatian presidency which is
being organized under the motto a strong
Europe in the world full of challenges
we didn't think when we drafted this
text back in October 2000 19:00 that we
were going to be faced with a covered 19
pandemic but still we wanted to put
among our priorities the dossier of
enlargement the southeast European
countries in the Western Balkans I can
proudly say that compared to the
blocking of the decision to open the
accession negotiations at the European
Council in October 2000 19 in the
meantime we have managed thanks to our
joint efforts to unblock this decision
and the European Council in March
confirmed the decision to open the
accession negotiations with North
Macedonia and Albania in our view as
Croatia these decisions were long
overdue secondly we have managed to
adopt a new methodology of the accession
negotiations so the new enlargement
methodology which I think is essential
at the outset of the work of the olefin
Alliance Commission and I think this
will help not only Montenegro and Serbia
who are negotiating accession since 2012
and to
in 14 but also in the future north
Macedonia and Albania we also wanted to
send a signal to the furthering of the
dialogue between Serbia and Kosovo
because this will not only normalize
their relations but help them to send a
positive signal to the stability of the
region and to move to other priorities
towards the European Union in particular
Croatia accentuated the Bosnia and
Herzegovina as our closest neighbor
country which in our view deserves the
status of candidate country we shall
continue to support them in the reform
process but also on their way towards
the European Union in this context we
emphasize the issue of equality between
the three constituent peoples in Bosnia
and Herzegovina and others and in
particular the position of the crowd
people and in terms of the legitimate
representation in the Bosnia and
Herzegovina highest institutions I think
that the assistance which the EU will
offer in the fight against kovat 19 -
the Western Balkan countries has been
confirmed that the next economic package
that the European Commission will
publish in order to support the Western
Balkan countries is very much awaited
that the new multi-annual financial
framework will take into account the
needs for the economic recovery of our
neighboring countries and not only the
EU member states and that politically
looking ahead with a lot of appreciation
to Chancellor Merkel and her initiative
of the Berlin process that has been sort
of putting together the leaders some of
the leaders of the UN leaders of the
region since 2014 I think we should
continue with a systematic holding of
summits of this nature at least every
two years in order to politically guide
our relationship in the future even
though our presidency unfortunately did
not happen in the way we wanted I mean
physically but in terms of substance I
think we delivered
in respect to the expectations that we
had and that our neighboring countries
had so a big thanks to all of the
leaders who participated and I'm sure
that the people and the nations in our
neighborhood will appreciate the message
which was today sent virtually from
Zagreb but literally from every single
European capital and the key European
and financial institutions thank you
Thank You mr. prime minister we have a
lot of questions also from regional
media please identify yourself with name
and medium before I pass the floor and
please state to whom you want to address
the question to we will start with Ed
Nest Hungary from euronews I believe ed
nest are you there
thank you yes I have for the presidency
and one for the Commission Prime
Minister plank of each you who are
heading the only country that 20 years
ago was sitting on the other side of the
table with a group of the Western
Balkans and today you are heading home
for the European Union if you recall the
statements of that time declarations of
Thessalonica how would you evaluate have
you achieved the messages of this Zagreb
declaration to be weaker equal or
stronger than those two decades before
and president from the lion I wanted to
ask you is this pandemic affecting
somehow the timeline of the Commission
in terms of the enlargement work or
maybe some reforms in the countries and
what would you like to see happening
during this year in 2020 in terms of
concrete steps let's say for example
with both Macedonia venya Montenegro you
can add other countries situation thank
you
should we answer immediately yes okay
thank you very much for posing this
question well I not only was physically
present back in 2000 I participated from
Brussels perspective to prepare that
thessaloniki summit I was in Sofia and
Here I am again in the role together
with Sharla and Ursula as the co
organizer of this event I think if we
look at the nuances of the language in
all of these documents you can see the
progress and that's why I said in my
opening statement that the summit in a
way concludes the joint work that we did
since October till today I think the
Zagreb declaration is very solid very
substantive sends a strong political
support to all the countries in the
region fact that we finally made a
decision to open negotiations with north
on Macedonia and Albania and that we
have the new methodology and the summit
in the first six months of the mandate
of Cheryl and Ursula I don't think we
could actually be asking for more so
from our my perspective personally I am
very pleased and happy that we managed
to navigate through a lot of difficult
political and the diplomatic
negotiations and achieve the document
and the messages which we all heard
during last three and a half hours yes
to your question the pandemic and
concerning the timelines of the
enlargement process of course the
pandemic is a huge challenge to the
timelines of the enlargement process but
if we are smart and if we stand together
we might also use it as a push forward
to grow closer together because what we
all have in common now is that after the
lockdown we see a vast economic damage
in all our economies and we are heading
towards a recovery program and as the
the investment package of the European
Union will also look at the recovery
needs of the Western Balkans and if we
align and that's the goal our common
policies of interconnectivity
our policies of digitalization the
policies of the European Green Deal we
can leap forward we can bounce forward
together in common strategies how to
bring back the economies on our feet and
so far right now it's a challenge but I
hope looking back one day we say we made
the best out word out of it and we grew
faster together
thank you passing the flow now to Vedant
Riegert from deutsche welle
I believe that it's good evening thank
you I have two short questions one for
the prime minister and one for mrs.
Fonda line mr. blinker which should the
countries in the Western Balkans be more
grateful for the help that they get from
the EU should the Serbian president for
example kiss the European flag rather
than the Chinese and mrs. father line
did you take the opportunity to talk
about the European budget and the money
and the recovery fund and all of these
helps that also have to be financed
somehow for the Western Balkans well it
is not up to me to talk in the name of
any other leader that took part in
today's meeting especially coming from
our neighboring countries but what is
certain and what we could all hear is a
very clear and strong articulation of
all the six countries in the Western
Balkans that their objective is the
European Union this is there's finality
politic in terms of orientation and one
thing is certain this summit is helping
them to go in the right direction I
think there is a lot of appreciation in
all the capitals in the region for what
the European Union is doing these
countries are in a way surrounded by the
European Union if we look at geography
there is nowhere else they can go so
from my point of view this is something
that you will have to ask if there is
personally but I think there is an
understanding and appreciation for what
the European Union is doing in political
economic terms and especially in terms
of financing many projects in
infrastructure and also assisting in
fighting copy 19 pandemics
so my answer can be very short no the
European budget discussions were not
part of the discussions of today today
we had shall correct me if I'm wrong but
approximately 35 participants in this
summit and rightly so the whole focus on
concentration was on the EU Western
Balkan relationship and of course the
accession processes and growing closer
together okay passing the floor now to
Tania moleska from Mia Tania yes hi do
you hear me yes yes I have a question
for the three of you I mean today
Freedom House published its report and
Serbia and Montenegro has been for the
first time rated as the hybrid regimes
meaning they are not entirely democratic
this means that the two countries that
the European Union is negotiating with
are now hybrid regimes and this will
lead me to a second question do you
think that it's time to speed up the
process with no and Macedonia and
Albania in order to have maybe more
successful stories when it comes to to
negotiating an argument thank you
we thank you for the session we had the
occasion to to repeat that the reforms
are essential and the fight against
corruption the rule of law the de mettre
to achieve values those issues are
essential in the European perspective
and our message is very clear and that's
why it's so important to 20 new the
implementation of the reforms as
European Union will be very will be very
committed in order to be certain that
it's possible to make more progress on
those topics so the rule of law is the
corner stone of the European values and
its conditions in a quinone for any kind
of accession process so these reforms
have to be done and the progress have to
has to be shown that is true for every
country that wants to be a member state
in the European Union what the second
part of your question is concerned it's
a process that is pretty complex so
there are many many different topics
that have to be discussed in the
respective chapters therefore just only
speeding up because of the question to
be fast is not the right way to go but
the new methodology opens the
possibility to have in parallel a few
chapters so that you can speed up the
process and I hope this will be possible
with a new methodology now just just a
quick big addition I think in terms of
methodology of the accession
negotiations chapters 23 and 24 who are
dealing with fundamental rights who are
dealing with issues such as freedom of
press with the fight against corruption
with the rule of law with democratic
with democratic standards actually exist
in order to be used as a leverage in
speeding up the essential democratic
reforms and therefore the process of
negotiations I insist
it's a transformative process the more
countries who are
wonders of joining the European Union
are engaged the more reforms will be
successful staying somewhere in the
parking lot is not an incentive for
strong reforms even in this area we have
seen that elsewhere before thank you
well passing the floor now for two more
questions two last questions to Vince
Chadwick Vince can you hear us yes hi
thanks um my question is for president
Michelle about the European Bank
construction and development which is
invested 13 billion in Western Balkans
but is also considering an expansion in
to Stubb's are in Africa like to ask
whether you think that's a good idea or
not and whether SH that sends about the
European perspective and had more
broadly I'd like to ask Wayne if at all
you're planning to bring the question of
the featured especially IB in Africa and
also relatedly in Europe through your
head of state level because as you would
know from your previous role this
question is being discussed for a decade
and again it has come from but again
officials say they have no clear idea
what lead thank you for this important
question and indeed III think that is
very important in the European
perspective to be more active fact the
external level is what we are trying to
do with this important summit that we
had today but I think indeed it will be
also important in the future too to
consider that the relationships between
the European Union and the African
continent will be essential for our
common future and I have the impression
that in the framework of the next
negotiations related to the next
European budget it will be essential
also to identify which kind of strategy
we would like to develop towards Africa
and in my personal opinion I think
indeed it is important to invest more in
Africa
in our common interest it's important
for Africa is also very important for
Europe and the question will be asked
what are the tools that we can use the
European Investment Bank with his
expertise is a possible tool that we can
that we can use but it will be important
to have a very strong dialogue with the
African partners in order to identify
what's the best way of working in order
to be more efficient in order also to be
more visible as a European Union
European Union going to social
transformations so is there political
will within the council to understand
that it is important for countries to be
a part of future friends thank you thank
you for discretion and my answer is very
clear yes there is a European
perspective there Eastern European
perspective and if you look at the
situation a few months ago we were
decided at the European level it was
very difficult to have the same position
about the possibility to open the
negotiations talk with Albania s and
with northern Macedonia and because of
our political involvement we have agreed
a very strong position in March a few a
few months ago and we have taken the
decision to open the tolls with northern
Macedonia
not Macedonia and with Albania and our
message is very strange is also very
clear and certainly after discovered 19
crisis is essential to develop a very
stern strategy with this region in order
to invest in the short term in the mid
term in the long term and in parallel
it's important for the region to reduce
the tensions to continue all the efforts
in order to implement the reforms but I
repeat at the highest European level
opinion today I'm talking about
countries of which France is one of the
most important thank you about the
conference on the future of Europe we
are in description which said the
European Parliament in order to to agree
about the the modality that concrete
modalities and of course in during this
conference it will be important to
discuss all the possible topics my
opinion is certainly it will be
important to involve the European
citizens to work with the different
European institutions to involve the
European citizens and if it's possible
to develop also a kind of dialogue with
all the regions in the world and
especially with the Western Balkans it's
a topic that we will discuss with the
other institutions madam president
yes thank you indeed as the conference
on the future of Europe will be a
conference with the European people and
how they see the future of the European
Union automatically there will be the
topic of enlargement and how to
integrate our Western Balkan friends so
it will be a part a module of the
conference for the future of Europe
thank you to all participants thank you
to the two presidents and from Zurich of
course with the Prime Minister thank you
and stay safe and see you next time
[Music]
you